I want to talk about grief a bit so I've
lost a number of like I mentioned close
friends and a mentor in the last 12
months
and you mentioned your husband who
passed away earlier and if I get any
facts wrong obviously please yeah but
colorectal cancer 42 I'm 40 which really
caught my attention and my the first
time I had an opportunity to go abroad
outside of the United States was to
Japan as an exchange student and I lived
with a family went to a Japanese high
school and I'm still close to that
family 25 years later and the father and
that host family is my second father
effectively and I plan on bringing my
American family to Japan later this year
to meet them for the first time my two
families and I just found out that my
host father is in the hospital
late-stage very aggressive cancer
diagnosed as metastasized probably will
pass away in the next two months and
what kind of cancer it's I would have to
go back to the email because it was very
emotional and then cognitively difficult
for me to translate because there's
lights in Japanese and it was all
specialized medical terminology but it's
it's in the lung it's in the liver a
lifelong smoker very typical for
Japanese of that age I think it might be
also esophageal so this is had me
thinking about grief and is there
anything I should do in advance to
prepare for that and I'd just be very
curious if you're willing to talk about
it to describe your experience of
grieving and you could start at any
point in time but as it relates to your
experience with with your husband
certainly after that we can get into it
but I mean you've done a tremendous job
of highlighting the types of diagnostic
tools and preventative tools that people
can use image image we'll talk about but
I don't even know how to think about
grief I mean I don't know if I've
allowed myself to ever experience it
before but I know I'm gonna be hit with
a hammer I thought though you had a
couple of friends I did know I did they
have passed away and it's been very
recent that it hasn't been this close
these are friends but they're not a
second father to me mm-hmm
and I think in a sense the the mentor
passed away it did hit me pretty hard
but I've only in the last six to 12
months actually been allowing myself to
feel more things that's a much longer
story by petal I have a kind of
conflicted relationship with this person
I know I've had a lot of armor for
decades and I've built up over time for
a lot of different reasons and it's been
very useful for some things for
protecting me but I've realized it also
keeps a lot in that is very ultimately
corrosive so I'm trying to develop more
of an ability to feel and instead of
looking at it as a liability gosh I
don't know how do you how do you
describe grief I mean I can I can talk a
little bit about my personal experience
you know I had a I was on top of the
world had this great job had two
beautiful children and of course a
wonderful husband I have to say we were
having challenges some challenges in our
marriage because I think I had this just
sort of out of the blue success and some
suddenly became a household name and had
all this attention which I think can put
a lot of pressure on a relationship or
suddenly it doesn't feel the power
dynamic doesn't feel as equal right but
you know we were we were really you know
in love and enjoying our lives and you
know just out of the blue Jay hadn't
been feeling well he had been tired he'd
been traveling and we kept thinking you
know we have two little kids he's
covering the OJ Simpson trial he was
you know his schedule was crazy and then
out of the blue he just was doubled over
in pain and our nanny who was Irish at
the time called and said J's doubled
over in pain and I don't know what to do
so he didn't have a doctor like so many
young men or just you know if anybody
takes their many I think takeaways from
our conversation I hope but one is that
men especially I think because women go
see gynecologist
honestly that a lot of men don't go and
get physicals or they don't even have a
GP or an internist and che was one of
those guys who played lacrosse and
football and in college and was never
smoked ever I don't think he ever even
tried a cigarette I never I don't think
he even tried pot ever it's sort of
crazy when you think about it drink
moderately took pretty good care of
himself I mean and and it just boom he
had stage 4 metastatic colon cancer so
we went from one day just everything was
great we were buying a house in the
country and or had a house in the
country and we're really enjoying that
and J was riding horses in Central Park
and doing his thing professionally and I
was at the Today Show and our girls were
great and we had I mean Carrie was less
than a year at the time or just had
turned a year old when he was diagnosed
on April 3rd 1998 1997 sorry he died
nine months later in January but you
know it's just it's so it's so
debilitating and shattering and
destabilizing and you know it's such a
process and I was in such denial and he
was one of these very smart people but
he didn't want to know about his health
he didn't want to know the gory details
I don't know why cuz he was so smart
intellectually curious and interested
and I don't know maybe he knew so I kept
all this stuff from him which I really
rat I would say oh there's only shadows
on your liver don't worry it's gonna be
okay
we're gonna figure it out I remember
sending his scans to NIH you know cuz I
had a lot of connections because of my
job and I remember very prominent cancer
scientists calling me and saying oh god
this is this is really bad he I arranged
for him to get a hepatic artery pump
which pushed the chemo directly to his
liver that was covered I mean the tumor
burden on his liver was awful and anyway
so I was I went into I think my my
husband John says I'm very good in an
emergency you know I get very focused
and very proactive and driven and I went
into I am going to try to fix this mode
and so I was sort of doing that I think
to avoid the grief because I had to do
something and it was just I mean what
can I say
it's the worst thing in the world to see
someone first of all your life just
changed in a instant then to see someone
suffering then to try to figure out how
can you help somebody I mean it's just
it's really overwhelming and you know I
think my grieving process began the day
he was diagnosed because my doctor who
was the internist Jay went to see when
he was in this pain
you know he pulled me aside into one of
those little patient rooms in the
hospital and said it's it's this is
really bad that the prognosis is very
bleak so what do you do with that except
for do everything you possibly can to
change the outcome which you realize you
probably can't change anyway it's a very
challenging thing to deal with but you
know I maybe my regrets will help you
with your situation and that I never
really said to Jay what are your hopes
and dreams for your kids
can you write the girls a letter can we
videotape you talking to them to say
everything I wanted to say to him
because that was an acknowledgment that
he was going to die and I just couldn't
do that so maybe if things are so bleak
for this person is so special to you
first of all you need to tell him no and
you need to write him maybe go see him
and feel that that you don't have any
regrets thank you
you